Olá pessoal aqui Dr Alan Machado Dutra
sejam bem-vindos a mais um vídeo hoje
nós vamos falar de três maneiras de
deixar o seu arroz mais saudável bem
pessoal é difícil encontrar um
brasileiro que não gosta de arroz então
no vídeo de hoje eu vou compartilhar com
vocês três dicas incríveis para deixar o
arroz mais saudável e assim evitar
aqueles Picos de glicose no sangue que
levam pré-diabetes até mesmo alguns
casos ao diabetes vamos falar um
pouquinho sobre os Impacto dos picos de
glicose no sangue os picos de glicose no
sangue são prejudiciais porque eles
podem elevar a resistência insulínica
aumentam o risco de desenvolver o
diabetes tipo do ou até mesmo
pré-diabetes causam flutuações de
energia danificam vasos sanguíneos e
nervos contribuindo para doenças
cardiovasculares e problemas renais
também afetam a visão e promove o ganho
de peso Então essas oscilações abruptas
do aça do sangue são muito ruins podem
ter impactos negativos significativos na
saúde geral na qualidade de vida e
aumentar o risco de várias doenças
várias condições crônicas Então pessoal
Será que o arroz branco é um vilão Você
já se perguntou porque que o arroz
branco tem fama ruim a razão principal é
o alto índice glicêmico que significa
que ele pode elevar rapidamente os
níveis de açúcar no sangue quase como
comer açúcar Então precisamos de um
equilíbrio na alimentação na maioria dos
casos podemos comer sim o arroz na
maioria dos casos desde que façamos de
forma consciente inteligente gente então
se você não fica sem o seu arroz limite
o consumo a uma refeição ao dia Evite o
arroz na janta e prefira no café da
manhã ou no almoço agora para quem é
fisicamente muito ativo Pode sim comer
arroz duas vezes ao dia vamos falar do
lado bom do arroz de feijão então o
clássico arroz e feijão é uma combinação
nutricional Interessante enquanto o
arroz é uma boa fonte de aminoácidos
metionina e cisteína ele deixa a desejar
qu se trata do aminoácido lisina então
aí que entra o feijão trazendo todos os
aminoácidos essenciais que faltam no
arroz inclusive sendo rico em lisina
então juntos Eles garantem que o nosso
organismo receba todos os aminoácidos
essenciais todos os nove que nós
precisamos vamos falar da diferença
então entre o arroz branco e o arroz
integral devemos optar pelo branco ou
pelo integral embora o arroz branco seja
o preferido na mesa da maioria dos
brasileiros de muitas pessoas o arroz
integral ganha pontos quando o assunto é
saúde comparado a arroz branco o
Integral é uma fonte de fibras e é mais
rico em vitaminas e minerais essenciais
ele nos oferece mais vitamina do tipo B1
a tiamina mais niacina que a B3 além de
uma quantidade maior de vitamina B6 ou
piridoxina o arroz integral também tem
mais minerais como magnésio manganês
fósforo ferro e Zinco vamos falar umas
palavrinhas sobre a relação entre arroz
e diabetes embora ambos os tipos de
arroz arroz tenam diferenças
significativas em termos de nutrientes
No que diz respeito ao impacto no
glicêmico nos níveis de açúcar no sangue
a história é um pouco diferente todo
arroz é uma fonte rica de carboidratos
então para quem tem diabetes ou
pré-diabetes simplesmente substituir o
arroz branco pelo integral não vai ser
importante não vai ter um impacto
esperado no controle da doença então
diabéticos podem ou não comer arroz
Depende de como está o seu controle de
glicemia e de como está a sua
alimentação em hábitos Gerais de vida se
você for esportista certamente poderá
comer se você não for esportista e tiver
um diabetes mais difícil controle aí não
é uma boa ide comer o arroz branco então
vamos para dicas para um arroz mais
saudável a dica número um é diminuir o
arcênio no arroz a planta do arroz tem
uma capacidade bastante alta de
concentrar de absorver e concentrar o
Arsênio chegando a absorver até 10 vezes
mais desse elemento do que outras
plantações e o que preocupa É que
geralmente o arroz contém um índice de
Arsênio inorgânico que é a forma mais
nociva desse metal pesado então a
pesquisa que foi conduzida em abril de
2016 o cientista do Darth Mouth College
revelou que os bebês que consumiam
cereais e papinhas a base de arroz
tinham níveis mais elevados de aceno
inorgânico na urina em comparação com
aqueles que não consumiam esses produtos
ou os que consumiam em menor quantidade
Então como podemos reduzir a exposição
do Arsênio no arroz uma dica valiosa é
cozinhar o arroz de uma maneira um pouco
diferente seguindo a técnica utilizada
pro macarrão o órgão Americano fda
recomenda cozinhar o arroz em uma grande
quantidade de água de seis partes de
água para uma parte de arroz e depois
drenar o excesso de água ao final do
cozimento essa prática pode reduzir os
níveis de Arsênio em até 60% a dica
número dois é arroz na geladeira
transformando ele em amido resistente
Então o que acontece com o arroz na
geladeira depois que você fez cozinhou e
esfriou quando o arroz cozido é
resfriado na geladeira parte do seu
amido se transforma em amido resistente
isso ocorre devido ao processo de
retrogradação do amido que muda a sua
estrutura tornando-se menos digerível
então isso vai ajudar a diminuir o pico
de açúcar no sangue quais são os
benefícios do amido resistente O amido
resistente Age de forma similar às
fibras AL alimentares ele não é
completamente quebrado e absorvido pelo
corpo mas ele é fermentado pelas
bactérias benéficas que vivem no nosso
intestino grosso então é uma boa ideia
para você melhorar sua saúde intestinal
usar amido resistente Qual que é o
impacto nos níveis de Açúcar do sangue
do Arroz consumir um arroz que foi
resfriado e transformado em amido
resistente pode ter um impacto muito bom
nos níveis de açúcar por ser menos
digerível leva a um aumento mais lento e
gradual da glicose sanguínea isso pode
ser especialmente útil para pessoas que
estão tentando controlar os níveis de
açúcar no sangue então deixe o arroz de
molho depois lave cozinha o arroz
normalmente e depois de pronto deixe
esfriar por algumas horas ou durante a
noite na geladeira antes de consumir
você pode reaquece ou consumi-lo frio
por exemplo a dica três é vinagre de
maçã antes de comer o arroz para ter o
quê uma baixa na glicemia o vinagre de
maçã ser consumido Antes das refeições
com carboidrato
Isso inclui o arroz pode ajudar a
moderar os níveis de açúcar no sangue o
vinagre de maçã como você já sabe que
vira meus vídeos anteriores tem o
potencial de atrasar o esvaziamento do
estômago o que contribui para um aumento
mais gradual nos níveis de açúcar no
sangue após a refeição Além disso o
vinagre pode melhorar a sensibilidade a
insulina otimizando a forma como o nosso
corpo utiliza o açúcar Então como
utilizar dilua uma colher de S de
vinagre de maçã e um copo de água e tome
essa mistura antes da sua refeição essa
prática pode ser particularmente
benéfica antes de refeições ricas em
carboidratos como aquelas que incluem o
arroz pessoal muito obrigado por ter
acompanhado esse vídeo até o final não
esqueça de divulgar esse vídeo nas suas
redes sociais Compartilhe o link com
seus amigos e familiares vão ajudar
outras pessoas a ter acesso a
informações de alta qualidade para que a
sua vida melhore
significativamente Muito obrigado o um
beijo no seu coração e você é Vera